more than four million prints and
negatives from ebony and jet magazines
were bought this week for 30 million
dollars the photos will be donated to
museums including the Smithsonian some
images captured the stark reality of the
black experience in America and we want
to warn you some of them may be
disturbing Adriana Diaz got access to
the archive the images are 70 years of
American history immortalized on too
glossy paper mostly in black and white
this Pulitzer prize-winning photo of
Martin Luther King's wife and daughter
at his funeral
Muhammad Ali stinging like a bee and a
crooning James Brown the images
humanized celebrities and celebrated
regular people the core of this
collection is our history it's the
essence of the black story in America
Perry uber is president of Chicago's
DuSable museum of african-american
history did you grow up reading Ivany
magazine I sure did I sure did you'd be
hard-pressed to walk into a black home
back in the day and not see the current
issue of ebony or Jet magazine truth we
knew we weren't getting someone else's
version of us but decreasing
subscriptions and rising debt forced
Johnson publishing to sell the magazines
and put its prized photo archives up for
auction who do we have here in this
drawer you hail Muhammad Ali archivist
Vicky Wilson gave us rare access to the
files no fingerprints allowed just look
at Rachel's playing dominoes who where
can you find an image like that we
travel with the Freedom Riders some
photos were a catalyst for change when
jet published the disturbing open casket
image a 14 year old Emmett Till who was
beaten and lynched in 1955 it sparked
the civil rights movement Rosa Parks
said she was thinking of till when she
refused to give up her seat these are
images Wilson once shared with future
generations why is it important to have
this record just to let me know that so
we can see how far we have come
you know there's hope in these boxes a
lot of hope hope and history preserved
in time heading to a new home
for CBS this morning Adriana Diaz
Chicago makes me so proud I'm so glad
people still get to see it
we'll be right back